thank you everybody for all of the
absolutely kind words and stories that
you all have shared
it just completely reflects on the type
of person that my dad was
i'm sean justin's oldest son and this is
my brother jacob
i'll have to start off with some dad
advice
pardon the cell phone notes as my dad
was a boy scout he told me always to be
prepared
well
let's say the notes didn't make it but i
thought of my dad and i took a picture
of the notes and here they are
so
as i can't really think straight right
now i'm gonna probably be reading off of
this more often than not
for those of you that know me
i really wanted to say something funny
to make you all laugh and smile
but i really wanted to say this from the
heart
first of all wow
the outreach
everything
that everyone has done for
my dad and our family has been nothing
short of incredible
however i'm not sure
this is what my dad would have wanted
because he hated being the center of
attention
sorry dad
you're gonna have to deal with it
because you were loved by so many
just seeing and knowing how many people
he touched in some way or another is
absolutely amazing
he truly was the best of us
and
as i've been told a hundred times over
by all of you
if you spent more than two minutes with
him you knew how amazing of a person he
was
recently i heard something of
that uh
someone said online
i don't know whether or not it's true
but knowing my dad i believe it to be
true
someone out there
said that he was the most kind and
polite police officer to have ever
arrested him
as crazy as that sounds you and i all
know that is probably true
to be completely honest i didn't know
what to say or right
my first thought
was that i needed to ask dad for some
help
he was the most well-spoken person
that i have ever known
and i'm not just saying that because i'm
biased
he deeply understood the most powerful
thing a person has is their words
trust me i can go on for hours telling
you all how great he was
but i will say that i cannot be more
thankful to have had him as a dad
i owe him everything for who i am today
i'm thankful that he was able to see me
grow up
and he was able to see my brother
recently graduate
i'm thankful that he was able to guide
me through a few years of adult life to
give me some good experience
to help
share to my brother
because i promised my dad
that i would care for him if anything
ever happened
my dad barely ever asked for help
and he always wanted to help others so
i'll try and leave you all with some of
the advice that he gave me
he knew and he understood his morality
her mortality
both as well
it's a sad thing to think about but it
cannot be more true especially in this
line of work
tomorrow is never promised
life is too short to be upset
with those that
always tell them that you love them
and how you feel
there is always the chance that you may
never see them walk through that door
again
we knew he loved us and that he was
proud of us
and we were of him as well
because we said it
nothing was left unsaid
and we are extremely lucky to have peace
with that
there are others who cannot say the same
i will not miss anything more than those
big strong hugs that he gave when i said
i'll see you later
thank you
i just wanted to thank everyone for
coming out today in remembrance of my
dad
it's just amazing to see
all the lives that he has touched
yesterday was a very
rough day because yesterday was father's
day it was the first one with
our dad there
we had never imagined something like
that
but
there's
no words to describe how thankful i am
and how thankful we are for
all the time we got to spend with him in
all the father's days
we couldn't have asked for a
better dad to raise us to
who we are today
and who we will become
and we're so thankful we were able to
call him our dad
and
i know he hated
being the center of attention he's
probably a little mad right now
but
in my opinion he
deserves all the attention in the world
because he was the best of all of us
and
like sean said not i'm not biased
but he was the greatest man i have ever
met
he was the most selfless humble and
caring human being
and
something him and i would always do is
go to the movies and you know there's a
lot of
superhero movies
and even after
watching all those superheroes on the
big screen and everything
there was always
one hero i looked up to
and that was it
he was just the best person i could ever
look up to
he always has been and always will be my
hero
and
i found this quote i wrote it down in my
english notebook and
found it the other day actually my
girlfriend found it the other day
and came across it
and i forgot where i found it but i
wanted to share it that
it doesn't get easy
i want everyone to remember that
thank you
you